2024 is the year to travel
and this is your chance to join 1 group trip
You don't have anyone in your area who can join
or want to travel
and would you rather not be alone
then 1 group trip is ideal for you
and stand for this year
so far only Dubai and malaga on the schedule
to be alone of course
available for more months
and we want to organize more trip
and for that I need your help
so you have 1 idea for 1 destination
please let us know
and also let us know in which
month you would prefer that
it is quite difficult to really 1 good date
where several people can also work
school holidays
so holidays
let us know
and also for the summer holidays
we also want to offer holidays
we had last year
1 agreement organized for Greece
and that was super fun
so we want to do that again this year
but maybe in one other place
so any ideas are welcome
and also for city trips or can travel
let us know